let's say that h a represents a generic
weak acid and b represents a generic
weak base
if our weak acid donates a proton to our
weak base that would form a minus and hb
plus
to identify conjugate acid-base pairs
remember there's only one proton or one
h plus difference between an acid and
its conjugate base
so when h a donates its proton and turns
into a minus a minus must be the
conjugate base two h a
so there's one h plus difference between
h a and a minus they are a conjugate
acid-base pair
when b accepts a proton it turns into hb
plus therefore hb plus must be the
conjugate acid to
b
since there's one h plus difference
between b and h b plus they are a
conjugate acid-base pair
let's look at the situation where the
equilibrium constant for this reaction
is greater than one if k is greater than
one that means at equilibrium there are
more products than reactants therefore
the equilibrium favors the formation of
the products
for acid-base reactions the equilibrium
always favors the side with the weaker
acid and the weaker base
therefore since the equilibrium favors
the products the weaker acid and the
weaker base are on the product side and
the stronger acid and the stronger base
are on the reactant side
so when comparing our two acids h a and
h b plus
h a is the stronger acid of the two and
when comparing our two bases b and a
minus
b is the stronger base of the two
when the equilibrium constant is less
than one that means at equilibrium there
are more reactants than there are
products
therefore this time the equilibrium
favors the formation of the reactants
and the equilibrium always favors the
side with the weaker acid and the weaker
base
since the equilibrium favors the
reactants the weaker acid and the weaker
base are on the reactant side and the
stronger acid and the stronger base are
on the product side
so comparing our two acids h a and h b
plus this time hb plus is the stronger
acid of the two and for our bases b and
a minus this time a minus is the
stronger base of the two
let's look at an example of a weak acid
weak base reaction
the hydrogen sulfate anion will react
with the carbonate anion to form the
sulfate anion and the hydrogen carbonate
anion
looking at the reaction the hydrogen
sulfate anion is donating its proton so
that must be the acid and the carbonate
anion is accepting a proton so that must
be the base
after the hydrogen sulfate anion donates
its proton it turns into the sulfate
anion so4 2 minus therefore the sulfate
anion must be the conjugate base to hso4
minus
so one conjugate acid-base pair is hso4
minus and so4 2-minus
and when the carbonate anion accepts a
proton it turns into the hydrogen
carbonate anion therefore the hydrogen
carbonate anion must be
the conjugate acid to the carbonate
anion
so our other conjugate acid-base pair
consists of the carbonate anion and the
hydrogen carbonate anion
the equilibrium constant for this
reaction at 25 degrees celsius is
greater than one
therefore the equilibrium favors the
formation of the products and because
the equilibrium favors the formation of
the weaker acid and the weaker base we
know that the weaker acid and the weaker
base must be on the product side and the
stronger acid and the stronger base are
on the reactant side
therefore the hydrogen sulfate anion is
a stronger acid than the hydrogen
carbonate anion and the carbonate anion
is a stronger base than the sulfate
anion
let's look at another example of a weak
acid weak base reaction
in this case hydrofluoric acid reacts
with ammonia to form the ammonium ion
nh4 plus and the fluoride anion f minus
because hydrofluoric acid donates a
proton it's an acid and because ammonia
accepts a proton ammonia functions as a
base
and when hf donates a proton it turns
into f minus the fluoride anion
therefore the fluoride anion is the
conjugate base to hf
and when ammonia accepts a proton it
turns into nh4 plus the ammonium ion
therefore the ammonium ion is the
conjugate acid to nh3
let's say that we mix equal moles of our
weak acid hf with our weak base nh3 and
our goal is to figure out if the
resulting solution is acidic basic or
neutral first we need to determine if
the reactants or products are favored at
equilibrium and to help us determine
that here we have the ka and kb values
for our acids and bases so here's the ka
value for hydrofluoric acid at 25
degrees celsius so all these are at 25
degrees celsius here's the kb value for
ammonia the ka value for the ammonium
ion and the kb value for the fluoride
anion
so looking at our two acids that was
hydrofluoric acid and the ammonium
cation the ka for hydrofluoric acid is a
higher value than the ka for the
ammonium cation therefore hydrofluoric
acid is the stronger of the two the
stronger acid of the two
and for the two bases we have ammonia
and we also have the fluoride anion
looking at the kb values for ammonia the
kb value is higher than the kb value for
the fluoride anion therefore ammonia is
the stronger base of the two
so we have the stronger acid and the
stronger base on the reactant side and
the weaker acid and the weaker base on
the product side we know the equilibrium
favors the side with the weaker acid and
the weaker base therefore the
equilibrium favors the formation of the
products
so we could go ahead and write the
equilibrium constant for this reaction
is greater than one
and at equilibrium we're gonna have more
of our products than we do of our
reactants so to determine if the
solution is acidic basic or neutral we
have to think about the ammonium cation
and the fluoride anion in aqueous
solution
since the ka value for the ammonium
cation is greater than the kb value for
the fluoride anion the ammonium cation
is better at producing hydronium ions in
aqueous solution than the fluoride anion
is at producing hydroxide anions in
aqueous solution
so the concentration of hydronium ions
will be greater than the concentration
of hydroxide anions and therefore the
resulting solution will be acidic